does drinking hold you back as a
business owner in this video I'm gonna
dig deep and explain it hi I'm Evan
Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got asked a question from one
of my newsletter readers Chad love you
guys who wrote in to say hey Evan my
name is Chad and I'm a Toronto
photographer Toronto and City trying to
make it big I recently found you on
YouTube and I'm already a huge fan
thanks man
your videos are really inspiring have
helped me shape up and keep focused one
of the biggest things I've realized
after watching videos is that drinking
has really helped me back from achieving
the things I want in life
it's constantly makes me unhealthy makes
it impossible to wake up early and so
I've quit drinking altogether and I feel
great because of it this got me thinking
do all successful people avoid booze if
so I was wondering if you could make a
video showing the correlation between
sobriety and success thanks again for
posting your videos you're too
inspiration your friend Chad
so Chad this is an interesting question
and one that I haven't been asked before
what the correlation between drinking
and success as an entrepreneur is are
continue that I don't have any data I
don't have stats I haven't done the
study I don't know if anybody has but I
don't have that information what I can
tell you is my story and my experiences
so personally I'm not a drinker I grew
up in a family where alcohol was always
available I'm half Italian and so it's
customary to to have your own wine my
dad makes his own wine it was always
available whenever I wanted it but I
never I never took to it you know my
friends were never huge drinkers I'm not
naturally drinker I never drink by
myself and you know my wife is more of a
drinker and if somebody brings it up you
know if I'm at a party or my wife wants
to have a drink I'll always join in I'm
not afraid to do it it's just not not
something that I never get to feel like
I wish I had a beer right now or I could
really use you know whatever drink right
I just it's not it's not in man there it
wasn't part of my growing up that being
said I honestly don't think there's a
high correlation between being sober and
being a successful entrepreneur I also
don't think there's a high correlation
between being drunk all the time and
being a successful entrepreneur I think
if you're looking at entrepreneurship
it's really going to come down
to doing something that you believe in
and that your passion vote that's the
that's the biggest thing that leads to
success as an entrepreneur everything
else almost doesn't matter it's almost
like saying to be successful as an
entrepreneur you need to be outgoing
well it's not the case you don't need to
be outgoing or you need to be a vegan
well you don't need to be a vegan right
or you need to do X Y Z none of those
things really matter the only thing that
really matters is having that passion
and really believing in what you're
doing I think what's more important more
interesting to look at is the
environment and I'm a big believer that
the environment that you're in holds you
where you are and if you want to break
free and achieve the next level of
success you need to create a new
environment for you so does your current
environment allow you to be great or is
it holding you back to where you are and
I think in your case you know anything
that's debilitating anything that's
holding you back anything that is a
negative in your life you want to try to
remove it right because as long as
that's there you're not going to be able
to go here so by you removing alcohol
from your life that allows you to focus
more that allows you to to spend more
time on your craft grow your business I
think that's great
there may be other things in your
environment too if you look at the
friends and the videos you watch and
your family in the books you read in the
media consuming all that stuff things I
keep talking about removing those things
and changing them and putting in new
habits and new structures and new
friends and new people into your life a
new inspiration will help you become
more and more great so the more you
surround yourself with greatness the
more likely you are gonna be great so I
think if alcohol is a problem for you if
alcohol something that's preventing you
from doing some amazing things and yes
removing it from your life will help you
stay more focused and help you
accomplish your goals
I think if alcohol is something that you
do socially and is not a huge must-have
in your life then then removing it
probably wouldn't have a huge impact on
you either way so I'd encourage
entrepreneurs to one again follow their
passion make sure you love what you're
doing and then create an environment and
a structure around you that supports you
to accomplish your big goals and your
big dreams believe so that's my quick
take on it thank you Charlie for the
question never been asked out before so
you made me think a little bit for those
of you watch
I'd love to know what you think does
being sober help make you be a better
entrepreneur leave your thoughts below
I'd love to hear from you and if you
liked this video and you want to see
more don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and the newsletter thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon